travis got sued
over predictable and preventable after
world tragedy a spin story he's been
sued by a concert goer who was injured
during the asteroid tragedy on friday
night which left eight people dead
and 300 more injured in the suit manuel
souza filed the lawsuit against travis
scott himself as an organizer score more
and concert behemoth live nation
claiming the deadly disaster was
predictable and preventable motivation
for profit at expensive constant concert
goers healthy and safety and the
encouragement of violence a second suit
was filed by christine paredes the suit
named
travis scott and drake as defendants and
are accused of negligence it alleges
that drake came on stage alongside
travis scott and helped inside the crowd
and the crowd became chaotic and
stampede began leaving eight dead and
dozens injured kristen paredes severely
injured uh the devastating incident
occurred when a large portion of the
festival 50 000 person crowd attempted
to rush to the front of the stage during
scott's headlining set all at once
resulting in fans crushing each other
and the story continues it's a lot more
than that by the way on how a security
guard was injected
uh when he was trying to help somebody
and he passed that they took him in
apparently the needle had the uh
authorities said that they watched the
video interview witness and review
concert protocols to determine that
eight people that have used them
as soon as he jumped off the stage it
was like an energy took over and
everything but
there's a story it was narcan is what
was in it right it was revived by the
opioid antidote narcan
and then at the same time travis got
performed for an additional 37 minutes
after that took place so there's a lot
of different things i have some numbers
that i want to share and then i'll get
your thoughts on this because i'm
curious to know what you guys think
about this so here here's the number one
question who is held accountable for
this because this is another one of
those similar situations as what
happened with alec baldwin and he's the
producer if you're the executive
producer you're in charge astroworld
that's his product so you're held
accountable now a few things number one
rolling stones experienced this when a
fan died in 1969 at a concert and that
became something that everybody kept
bringing it up bringing up the place
where they did a lot of people said that
it didn't have capacity this place can
fit 200 000 people and there was only 50
000 so it's not like it was a capacity
problem when they say how many people
were working there there was 528 total
officers police officers
morning day shift and nycha 528 total
the day shift people were working
overtime and it had 755 security
officers whether that's high or low
that's a lot of people that they had
working there right
fans who were nurses were coming out and
helping out because they didn't have
enough you know people were being
dropped i don't know if you saw that
video with people being dropped and then
on top of that 25 arrests uh you know
you see things like this happening at
concerts but not at this level the part
that's very disturbing is the fact that
after the crowd is screaming you go for
another 37 minutes
did they know did they not know who
knows at this point of the game what are
your thoughts about what happened uh no
obviously it's it's a travesty on that
end there's there's no doubt about it
and we've all seen videos from the crowd
people screaming people saying stop
um
i think the the interesting part is
definitely the last part that you
mentioned where they went on for the
show after it was uh declared a mass
casualty uh declaration
and some say like obviously um his his
girlfriend kathy jenner came out and
said obviously we didn't know we didn't
know until afterwards but somebody must
have known and that's i think just a
failure of communication or
why they wouldn't let it go up the chain
so so that he can find out so they could
stop it in even when i heard there was
an ambulance driving through the um the
crowd as well and like people were
hopping on it like that's just insane
like there's no
sense of reasonable and obviously at
that point you're seeing something's up
like an ambulance just doesn't go
through the crowd for no reason yeah so
i definitely think that there's a lack
of a lot of failure points there um
i'm on the other side though i don't
think that too much is going to come out
of the lawsuits i'm sure they'll get
some sort of uh some sort of uh
compensation for it but beyond that i
don't see it being anything big uh i
just hope this could be more of a lesson
for for anything like this in the future
as well well i think there's going to be
some big stuff that's going to happen
here this isn't just one person down
this is a mass casualty event so let me
paint a picture for you uh when's the
last time that you were at a concert
even remotely this insane two years ago
where were you oh no it
probably in in years right yeah okay
more than a decade you've never been to
a travis scott concert or a hip-hop
concert in years
rolling loud anything have you been
anything like this recently uh no okay
so i've been to a bunch of these again
live in downtown miami rolling loud is
here every year i know the co-founders
of rolling loud buddies of mine lived in
my building and i know these people that
put these events on it there's a lot of
work that goes on to these events i've
seen travis scott in concert probably
three or four times and they've been one
was in okeechobee florida which is sort
of like a
it's a little more of a hit what's the
audience that the three or four you've
been to us at all 50k 25k big numbers no
no no one was at the miami heat arena
which is now
17k exactly wasn't that crazy but i've
been to one event at rolling loud where
he performed that it gets wild that was
just at rolling line we filmed david
when did we film that june july yeah
okay
so here's what you need to know about
travis scott and and for the record he's
probably one of my favorite rappers out
there
and
the reason
why this happened at an event like this
and a performer like this is that he
relishes getting the crowd hype or as
he's literally coined lit
like he's probably the one that has made
it's lit famous more than everybody now
everybody talks about it's lit it's lit
that was travis scott so the point is
this he has music and songs and the way
that he does his show that gets the
people
hype like no other so basically what
happened was
you know he's from houston
this was his event it's not like it was
just a random pop-in like drake popped
into this event to sing one song they
have a song together called uh sicko
mode that people literally go sicko mode
on um the mayor
the police chief know him personally
again he's from houston
apparently they had a conversation with
him before the event they were like look
we know that crowds in your world go
wild
just just be mindful of that before the
event did you see what happened prior to
the event like the stampede people have
you ever seen anything like that the
stampede
set the tone
for this event yeah hundreds and
hundreds of people
not just sneaking in
crushing stampeding through gates
competing through security it was insane
apparently
he tweeted before like
um
let's get um let's get raid let's let's
get the i want the ragers i want the
wild people to be here
tiffany our friend tiffany does social
media she's you know how often does she
get
into these stories she's been
so upset for the last you know days that
i've seen her
she's like i'm so upset at this person
because she's been to events like this
and it's so easy
to
for this something to happen because
here's the deal
the person that holds the mic has the
power the person that holds the mic has
control if you want the crowd to get
crazy wild lit rage
that you can do that that's the power of
the mic there's like this is powerful
what we're talking to on the flip side
if you want the crowd to chill out
back up calm down you can also do that
there's been events like rolling loud
where
there's been a musical guest like asap
rocky this is trending right now where
they've given an example of there's mosh
pits are people going crazy there's you
know getting hyped getting lit and he
goes everybody there's a girl on the
floor stop the show stop the show the
show pauses give it five minutes
get things regrouped in the middle of
all this this is probably the saddest
thing
while people were literally dying
getting stampeded getting run over he
kept performing there's a viral video of
a girl
climbing onto the stage yelling stop the
show there's a gentleman right after her
like people were aware of this
so you asked the initial question who's
liable here number one this is a live
nation event that's iheart media they're
going to have some prices to pay right
travis scott the person that this is
astro world this is his event there's
going to be some prices to pay the
promoters the lack of security the crowd
control
eight plus people we don't know people
who are injured eight people have died
okay this is i mean the last event that
i remember something live people cardiac
arrest i mean cardiac arrest at a
concert especially for young people
people are getting hype man and it's
like this is also
people probably don't want to address
this this is also on the crowd
this is also on the crowd whip you know
like i've been in events like this when
the crowd is getting crazy david when we
were filming it rolling loud i said
let's get out of here bro this is
getting a little too wild we had camera
equipment we're remember we said let's
stay towards the back yeah absolutely
people are getting
wild so when you have people on the
floor people are being stampeded but
people are
wasted drugged out whatever they are
that's at a festival things like this
happen you have to be aware of your
fellow man and fellow woman and if
there's someone on the ground you can't
just like oh well good luck buddy so
hopefully this is a wake-up call then
when you're out there you're partying
you've got to party responsibly but the
end of the day the person with the mic
is travis scott and he's going to be
held accountable
you have something there
i was trying to send you a file here's
what i did okay you can't get it i
pulled up 11 of the deadliest concert
disasters in recent recent history this
is a november eighth article
uh i don't know if you got that or not
uh
what is that background noise by the way
there's a little bit of static okay 11
of the deadliest yeah deadliest concerts
uh go to it the last concert that i
remember that was this tragic was the
ariana grande that but that was uh
that's the one that's the one click on
that one
click on that one
so let's go down to this
okay astroworld eight
dead at a 50k
rockslide festival in denmark nine
this was in 2020. is that a shooter as
well no
uh nine men were killed at pearl jam
concert well rushed to the stage and
those on the front collapsed okay uh
okay number nine uh the who at
cincinnati riverfront in 1979 11 death
11 people died more than 18 000 tickets
were sold at the whose concert in
cincinnati riverfront and there were
only 25 twins
oh my 25 police officers allotted for
the crowd control and they're set to
begin at 8 p.m but the doors were still
closed at 7 45 when an anxious crowd
here in the who's warm up and mistaking
them for opening numbers search towards
the door general admission seating made
up eighty percent of tickets so okay
next one is the ma wazing festival in
morocco 11 died
nine day memphis toronto was meant to
promote reputation of morocco uh next
one is what love parade germany in 2010
21
keep going ghost ship fire oakland uh
california 36 this is in 2016.
indiana state fair college stage
collapse so this is a collapse this is a
different instance 56 centica nightclub
fire okay that's a fire in thailand in
2900
station night club fire 100 that's in
rhode island 03 beverly hills super club
fire 165 that's uh
southgate kentucky 1977 and then
chrominone fire
194 but these are different reasons on
what happens so because the first four
are fires so let me let me ask you this
let me ask you to set up how many times
have you gone to a club where you've
seen guys passed out on the side and
they're they're on g or they're drunk
and they're just completely gone right
yeah that's all the time when you go
every time you go out you're gonna see
someone who just is messed up okay for
sure so for the for the people that go
to parties a lot and they see that to
them it's what just another guy that's
mess that's gone right right i don't
think too many people overthink oh
that's right liquor buddy i wonder who
saw that and is thinking hey that's
what's going on the difference is
nobody's sitting down there's not a
couch there's not like you're sitting by
a lounge area the guy's on the ground
they're stamped stomping over this guy
one girl says i was holding him i was
telling people to stop they couldn't
hear me the place was so loud she's you
know crying in tears saying people
couldn't stop and i remember when he
died he was he died in my arms just 20
year old kid girl is telling these
stories so it's it's tragic what happens
the only thing is when you see something
like this is what can you do to prevent
this okay
so go to preventative measures how do
you prevent these things from happening
again is it more security the bigger
claim was the fact that there was not
enough nurses the biggest fact was that
they cnn interviewed a girl that was
there with her boyfriend who says i
wasn't drunk i was totally fine i was
sober i felt like i was dying i felt
like i was having a heart attack he says
i was in the middle i told my boyfriend
i want to get out of here i can't even
breathe anymore i don't know if you saw
that interview or not and then she says
i go to the back they'll give me a
bottle of water
three people are passed out i go and
check their paws i said that guy's got
to go to the hospital i think he's dead
because he doesn't have a pulse and she
says i'm a nurse they were calling
everybody because they didn't have
enough people that were there so to me
everything is fine the lawsuits are
going to come out it ain't going to stop
this is not going to be pretty for live
nation or himself i think drake's
probably going to be left alone because
sue and drake if drake's not an astro
world is he does he own the brand that's
not his brand right they want to throw
his name in there
totally fine he's just doing what he's
doing he was a performer for one song
yeah but at the but travis scott's going
to be held in charitable uh live nation
is going to be held accountable they're
trying to hold the cops accountable i
think the chief came out and talked
yesterday he says i gave the numbers
incorrectly
he says we are very good at doing these
things he said the media is
saying that we were not prepared for it
that is that is not true we were fully
prepared for this these sorts of things
is tragic the only people that are
struggling right now the most are the
parents or the family that lost so
they're trying to
mitigate the situation
but it's not a pretty sight the only
thing i think about what do you do to
prevent this in the future yeah well
here here let me paint a picture for you
because again i've been to multiple
festivals like this sometimes i cover
them for valuetainment sometimes i just
go um
there's more than one stage usually at
these big events
so there's the main stage which i assume
he was performing at at his concert and
then there's gonna be maybe another one
or two
you know
uh ancillary stages right they're not
the main stages so what happens is
they'll have different events staggered
throughout so at state the main stage
the astro world stage travis goes on at
9 30. there's another artist over on
that side of the event that goes on at 8
30. there's another event that goes on
over here he's on 8 20. so there's these
staggered events right and basically
what happens is
once the event that you're at let's say
you're listening to little nauseas over
here i'm just throwing out i'm not even
sure he was there i'm just using an
example his set ends at 8 55. travis
scott starts at 9. everyone's aware as
soon as this is over get your ass to
travis scott everyone's there to see
that so the crowd moves from here and
rushes over here and there's no assigned
seating it's just get in where you fit
in so if you have 50 000 people if let's
say you have 20 000 that are already at
the
travis scott stadium waiting and you've
got another 20 000 rushing over
it just becomes slammed trample moving
on so you ask preventative
i don't know how you prevent 20 000
people from scrambling this way there
needs to be a way of this there's people
that this is their job right crowd
control systematic approach these types
of events
but a lot of time it is chaos i've been
there moving from crowd to crowd
remember we went from one stage to the
this was we were at the event where the
baby made those um
and rolling loud those uh homophobic
references we were there we said this is
getting
insane we actually left right before
that
but
i don't know how you control 20 thousand
math like think about twenty thousand
people coming into a basketball game
they gotta go through turn styles they
gotta go through security yeah these are
people that are already in there and
just are free to move about
it's it is controlled chaos and if
you're not
head on a swivel awake you know
completely understanding your
surroundings you full-on can get
trampled on and then when everyone's
moving towards the stage because
everyone wants to obviously get as close
as possible to stage if you're at the
front of the the crowd near the stage
i don't know how you're going to get
back out that way and that's so like you
saw the video of the ambulance trying to
get through
how the hell does an ambulance get
through there and then when you're in
the middle of
travis scott music whether it's sicko
mode or butterfly effect or
goosebumps like the guy's got some
banging music
people are getting wild and now you have
an ambulance coming through you see that
you're jumping on top of the ambulance
you're not thinking clearly so there's
gonna need this this might reshape how
concentrated give me give me the order
of responsibility okay so you made a
very good point number one whoever is in
charge of the concert controls the point
of contact okay live nation
i don't know if it's live nation it's
number one travis scott to stop and say
guys let's get help for this is he
number one well i don't know if he's
number one
i'd say also a big thing for me would be
some sort of like the management team
like if we think of the vault right
you're at the vault you're kind of doing
your thing and you're talking you're in
your own headspace at that point right
you're doing your thing but it should be
somebody behind the scenes who pulls and
says head pat like here's a note or
something like something's going on here
that's for to me that's a very good pull
the plug that's a good point for
somebody to communicate so then the
question becomes did somebody
communicate to him to say hey eight
people are down that's it someone
communicates
so if they did apparently they did
yeah if patrick sees an ambulance in the
middle of the crowd i mean you stop it
he clearly saw the ambulance there's no
way you can't see it that's true so he
chose to go so that's to me look i've
ran events as large as 10 000 people at
mgm grand right where you see what's
going on
uh you have to be aware of what's going
on in a big way i remember we do events
and guys would come the night before and
sleep in front 2000 people would be
lined up and planted hotel would say you
guys can't do this anymore and it would
be stampede so we have to slow
everything down because a couple times
people would run and people fell yeah
one guy even bumped into my dad and my
dad almost fell you know security came
and said you know your dad almost fell
so people were running through they
didn't know was your dad
so i think there's a part of that where
crowd control running man that is very
dangerous when you do that that's number
one protocol changing no but number two
would be
i don't know man if you're on the stage
and you're seeing this has happened if
you pause and he said guys everybody
pause stop stop stop stop stop boom go
there okay well apparently he did say he
saw someone i guess to his left if he
was on stage he said somebody's passed
out get him up whatever yeah
unbeknownst to him it was a lot worse
than when someone passed out you got 37
minutes for somebody to say dude yes a
person's not breathing no chill out
you mean 37 minutes someone cannot
communicate that to you that's where the
the huge failure is it's understanding i
think here's the bottom line
it's understanding the big picture
ramifications of this event because this
event is going to be here today gone
tomorrow yeah but while you're in the
moment the crowd is hype you're on stage
you're feeling the effect the
performance you got
you know
all the
the the all the feels going on right now
i mean imagine if you're on stage 50 000
people are chanting your name you're
feeling some type of way right
you have to have the ability to say guys
pause give it five minutes back up
again the person with the mic has the
power and he had the power to stop this
and unfortunately he didn't well we'll
see what's going to happen because these
things are moving fairly quickly right
now every day you're hearing something
new about it tmz had the story about the
guy getting poked in the neck yeah the
security guard
yeah we're gonna see where this is gonna
go somebody said somebody said they were
spreading coveted shots and all this
stuff you know there was a lot of
conspiracies that yeah i don't i don't
get all that i mean i've been to many
festivals i think those are just like
ancillary random stuff but let's not
forget the main thing is that people
died while have trying to have a good
time this wasn't like a stage that fell
this wasn't a fire
this was people this is the last thing
we need is people fearing another reason
to go to a live event to be around each
other it's like the last thing you need
to have another thing added to it go
ahead tyler well just real quick you
know this reminds me a lot of black
friday on a much bigger scale like when
everybody was rushing in the door black
friday but that stopped because you can
do online shopping now so there's been a
lot of talk about the metaverse how long
and does this lead credence to the idea
of people just slap on an oculus and
they go to a live event through their or
not a live event but but a concert
through their their virtual reality in
the metaverse they can dress up as their
character this set and the other it's
like does this speed that up at all and
how does this change you know live
events going forward i think that's a
good point but look i think live events
people have been
yearning to get the hell out there and
have a good time i don't see that
happening anytime soon especially with
the limited the limited access we've had
to live events like people are probably
craving it more now than ever but
interestingly enough there's a
correlation here too though if you think
about it with uh all the aggression and
sports and view people have been
watching going to live events in sports
and the fights and crowds yes yes it's
kind of like there might be some
correlation here to uh to crash it's
almost like people haven't been able to
leave the house for the last year and a
half how they don't want to act yeah
they don't know how to behave
um
on on another note
the the the kardashian jenner clan
they're gonna they're gonna they're
gonna get some hate themselves i know i
don't know about disney's they're gonna
get a lot of hate because they were
there kendall was there kylie was there
they were in the vip section they were
you know snapchat and doing insta
stories she kylie had a mask on or yeah
i mean look that's where they should
have been i don't think there's anything
wrong with that see anything but there's
an ambulance in her instagram story
so like she's like i wasn't aware but
there's an ambulance in her story so
it's like oh yes
but there's a difference between getting
criticism there's a difference between
getting sued there's a difference
between knowing somebody your love is no
longer here anymore so there's levels to
the kind of pain you're going to go
through believe me they would gladly
change their exchange exchange their
current uh struggles of being hated
i feel i feel for the parents of the
teenagers and 20-something-year-old kids
that said hey mom i'm going out to the
concert all right have fun call me when
you're done
and there was no calling i saw footage
of a brother saying my brother's no
longer here with me
together that was ridiculous listening
to this kid crying was so painful
anyways our condolences goes out to the
entire family
of those who lost their loved one at
this concert
prayers goes out to your family